in Denmark there's little appetite for
large campaign rallies
candidates hit the airwaves to convince
voters they have solutions to the
country's problems this is an election
that comes against the backdrop of war
in Europe Rising inflation an energy
crisis and climate change if you look at
the major decisions being made in
Denmark 90 of all major decisions are
being based being based on a broad
majority across the middle of the
political spectrum and of course I think
that is the best thing prime minister
and leader of the Social Democratic
party metaphroduction is desperate to
build a strong Coalition of Centrist
parties
for decades Danish politics have been
dominated by governing coalitions Paul
suggests that the social Democrats are
likely to remain the most popular party
But the irony is that for the
left-leaning SD to stay in power it may
need support from the right
Direction faces a growing backlash over
her decision to slaughter all of the
country's farmed mink in 2020 over fears
that could spread a mutated variant of
the Coronavirus
the Prime Minister survived a
parliamentary investigation but was
forced to call a snap election when her
main Ally the social Liberal Party
threatened to walk out of the coalition
the criticism from the so-called mink
commission was so heavy that it was
impossible not to take a consequence of
that
but besides that the whole history of
Denmark has been coalitions between
parties we had created this welfare
state together so the idea of having a
one-party government like in other
countries we don't compare ourselves to
it's not right for the far right this is
the moment they've been waiting for they
say if elected they will push for Harsh
anti-impiguration policies
we will never support a Social Democrat
government the prime ministers according
to us acted against the Constitution and
it's important that meteor Frederickson
doesn't continue as prime minister
this is Denmark's King maker Lars Luka
Rasmussen is a former prime minister and
his centuries party the moderates is now
projected to become Denmark's third
largest party but for now candidates
from the right and the left are
embracing nearly the same policies and
thus further puzzling voters half of
them are yet to decide their choice
Copenhagen